[Musique]
est-ce qu'elle a eu raison de quitter
tpm p vous nous dites et après ça donc
c'est un truc bien sûr avec vous tous
ici alors tiens je vends la vie de
valérie benguigui
alors moi je dis que oui et n'aura eu
raison parce que on ne retient pas
quelqu'un qui a envie qui ait envie de
partir
elle avait visiblement des doutes elle
avait visiblement des interrogations sur
son avenir sept ans elle s'est vraiment
à cycle donc pour elle visiblement elle
s'interrogeait elle nous en a tous parlé
en loge depuis quelques temps depuis
quelques mois je sais pas si je vais
rester je sais pas si je vais faire la
saison prochaine et donc appartement où
elle commence à s'interroger et à se
dire j'ai peut-être fait tout ce que
j'avais à faire dans touche pas à mon
poste c'est pas la peine de la retenir
et de l'obliger à rester pas leur jeu on
avait envie qu'elle retient voilà elle
va nous manquer bien évidemment jeu j'en
profite pour l'embrasser très fort mais
voilà si tu as envie de 6 à l'envi envie
de partir il faut la laisser grandir et
devenir une autre et nora gilles non non
et surtout pas comme ça moi j'aime
beaucoup et nora j'ai envoyé un message
pour lui dire elle m'a répondu gentiment
en disant qu'elle passerait nous voir
nous faire un câlin mais non pas comme
ça pas sur une vidéo un soir il faut
expliquer venir ici il fallait le dire à
la fin de la saison ciel voulez mais pas
comme ça
là j'ai l'impression que nos roms
abandonné en rase campagne au milieu de
la saison patois et non à mon nom je
vous vois comme ça
raison à la rue mais non je suis
d'accord qu'on voit gym je serais parti
aussi non parce que déjà on va arrêter
les conneries c'est la deuxième qui part
en veut pas de pot de départ j'ai failli
choper d'autrefois tir et moraux mais
était sur le plateau là elle était là et
puis non je suis d'accord avec valérie
évidemment que s'il avait envie de
partir jalal vous donner énormément elle
va beaucoup manquer les patients et une
animatrice de débats hors pair et elle a
beaucoup fait vivre on lui doit beaucoup
dans cette émission
après le seul petit reproche je pense
qu'elle a dû attendre la fin de la
saison
pas parce que on peut lui sourit quand
c'est une période un peu d'attenté et
dans ces cas là je pense qu'elle a dû
rester mais pour le reste c'est la
raison de partir elle a toujours été
honnête donc a été jusqu'au bout voilà
mais je vous le dis je voudrais juste
dire aux téléspectateurs n'y a pas du
tout de drame
oui nous ravva bien et je vous dirai
après voilà qu'est ce qui va
certainement se passer tout ça mais
vraiment voilà je vous parlais un peu
même de l'équipe et de ce qui va se
passer après vous dire que vous êtes un
peu d'accord aujourd'hui je suis n'est
pas illogique que j'ai eu au téléphone
ce week-end on s'est parlé elle devait
revenir lundi je sais pas ce qui s'est
passé au mouvement dans sa dans sa tête
évidemment s'il veut partir on va pas là
c'est son droit
moi ce que ce qui me dérange un chouïa
et j'ai appris à la découvrir parce que
je l'aimé pas du tout c'était ma
personne avant de la connaître
pardon mamie mais moi ce que je trouve
bizarre moi ce que je trouve bizarre par
rapport à ce qu'on s'est dit ce week-end
et sans la trahir
pourquoi le faire maintenant on voit le
vrai problème syndrome de timing
vous voulez qu'elle attendre la fin de
la saison rennes oui vous pouvez
attendre on est à quatre semaines de la
france n'était pas urgent de le faire
maintenant ce n'était pas sûrs à la fin
de l'émission on est en train de faire
en direct
je trouve le timing pas bon du tout et
je ne comprends pas voilà alors magali
vous êtes l'expert des experts pda dont
vous êtes extérieur à l'émission vous
vous dites non non moi je vais pas ce
que vous voulez je vous avais ts comment
vous avez pris voilà comment j'ai été
surprise après elle avait dit que la
télé elle pensait faire autre chose oui
en tant que téléspectatrice je suis déçu
moi j'ai regardé des pmp pourrait morin
quelques quelques années ensemble et à
beaucoup elle était entière elle avait
des coups de gueule on l'aimé on l'aimé
pas mais en tout cas avec allait se
passer quelque chose je pense que pour
l'émission c'est une perte voilà et je
suis déçu après effectivement je ne m'y
attends absolument pas et j'ai été prise
de court hier comme je pense tout le
monde mais voilà vous vous dites oui
mais bon je pense que c'est dommage pour
l'émission maintenant sur les dernières
images elle avait l'air et malheureuse
après je pense que elle prend aussi
énormément de coups sur les réseaux
sociaux
je suis allé voir hier justement et
honnêtement et prend des trucs d'une
boîte soudainement c'est vrai moi je
comprends cher qu'à un moment elle ait
envie d'arrêter ce que je pense que
c'est une fille qui est extrêmement
sympathique et qui à un moment je tiens
voilà elle l est et elle a un franc
parler qui est assez inégal et repousse
pour ça je pense qu'elle va elle va
manquer à l'émission mais un moment son
franc parler mais il ya un revers de la
médaille
et pour le coup je pense que l on a
peut-être marre aussi d'être toujours
considéré comme la méchante et d'avoir
peut-être envie de montrer une autre
facette de sa personnalité dont vous
trompez alors alors oui vous êtes tous
tellement figés sur les réseaux sociaux
que vous regardez pas la presse
enora dans la presse était la seule à
voir la carte el adha par cyril qui est
à part mais elle était bien vu de paris
match elle était bien vu du recours
elle était bien vu de technikart fallait
dire game 1 des harangues adapté en
animé
oui mais ça veut dire que dans la presse
qui compte je regrette elle avait une
bonne image complètement sauvage et
technikart
je les adore c'est pourri n'aura non
mais voilà je pense que les réseaux
sociaux compte aussi pour jean-michel
les réseaux sociaux comptent plus que le
libé aujourd'hui excuse moi je compte
bien sur les deux côtes mais moi je
trouve que l a eu raison partir ce que
vont le faire depuis sept ans ce n'est
pas une aventure qu'on peut qu'on ne
peut la vie jusqu'à 100% c'est ça on
peut pas on peut pas la faire à moitié
donc s'il vient il qu'on a plus
l'enthousiaste la la le fais pour moi là
mais plus enthousiastes la vérité mais
la vérité bas je pense qu'elles vont se
fait - non je pense qu'elle se sente est
peut-être moins désirés attaqué par par
certains téléspectateurs qui n'aimait
pas ce que c'était quelqu'un qui était
pas quelqu'un qui vend cirque où on
adore on est le test moi par exemple
personne madore personnes au 2e
trimestre alors qu'elle était là ou là
non on va essayer prouvons c'est vrai
ses poumons et donc ça ne va pas amener
à l'abonné n'aura pas ça va ne cherche
pas des copies sebastien bozon d'appeler
bercy
julliard je crois qu'en termes de
stratégie le problème c'est qu'elle
avait un peu les ailes et entre deux
chaises cette mère qui si elle tapait
fort et c'est d'ailleurs exceptionnel ce
qu'elle a fait penser cette année et à
côté de celle avait envie ce qui est
tout à fait logique qu'il avait de
l'ambition d'être animatrice où l'on lui
demander d'être beaucoup plus ronde et
est gentil avec et donc elle savait plus
trop où était sa place et je crois
qu'elle a choisi une voie celle de
devenir animatrice et d'être plus sympa
et deux de plus et dans comment elle
faisait comme ihsan al adha la punchline
dans le fight maxime non elle ne
laissait pas indifférente 7 est un des
piliers de l'émission sur des conneries
dire qu'elle n'avait pas sa langue dans
sa poche
elle avait une gouaille hors du commun
jour où adoré mais comment dit l'amour
dure soit 3 en septembre ou 9 ans elle
est peut-être parti au bon moment c'est
la présence je me pose juste une
question que va t elle faire aujourd'hui
à la télévision ces deux conneries ça
alors géraldine maillet alors moi je la
connais moins de vous a découvert cette
année je la connaissais pas avant et je
trouve que c'est une excellente
chroniqueuse qui était souvent à
contre-courant et souvent aussi dans la
contradiction contre vous et je la
trouve courageuse et désobéissantes et
je trouve que sa sortie et
désobéissantes est à son image
je la trouve très mauvaises au niveau du
timing me semble-t-il je pense que quand
on est dans une zone de turbulence en
période de mercato
quand on a un carton jaune ou quand le
club est relégué on reste on attend la
fin de la saison pour partir j'aurais
trouvé là peut-être plus élégant mais je
suis personne pour donner des leçons
d'élégance alors la région et j'ai vu
deux noms alors moi moi je veux juste
vous dire un truc je vais répondre à ça
parce que enora elle part quand elle
veut c'est elle qui décide et il n'y a
aucun problème dans tpm p as many chiris
est pas parce qu on a été un petit peu
attaquées l'émission va très bien on
continue à se marrer les clés
téléspectateurs sont là et on va
continuer à rigoler et à continuer cette
émission donc il n'y a aucun problème
n'y a pas de turbulences dans tpm paix
je suis désolé donc elle peut partir
quand elle veut voilà on mais il ya des
contrats aussi quand même oui voilà
après après je vous dire nous on essaie
mois le producteur et ne croyais et je
vais pas faire un un pro un procès
n'aura pas ce qu'elle est partie
conversation mais j'aime bien voilà
c'est ça oui moi j'avais l'impression
qu'elle était devenue elle avait peur de
devenir une caricature d'elle âmes elle
a beaucoup dit exhaler pour moi j'ai vu
en témoin privilégié ici deux tournants
le premier c'est le départ de thierry
moreau qui l'à beaucoup affecté parce
que je pense qu'elle était très proche
de lui il y avait un côté un peu famille
recomposée et ensuite une fois on a fait
son conseil de classe ici et ça a été
très dur pour elle parce que je pense
qu'on lui a dit qu'elle était plus une
chroniqueuse qu'une animatrice
c'est vrai et je pense que c'est quelque
chose qu'il a beaucoup laissé les
sensibiliser et blessés alors prenons ce
que vous en avez vous eu d'excès vous
regardez l'émission tous les soirs très
bien mon boulot alors vous dites la
vérité ce que vous l'aimiez ou pas
j'étais pas fan de noir
voilà donc si un téléspectateur nos
résidents mais dit la vérité donc pas
fan des nora maintenant moi si je serai
en penser qu'elle a bien fait de partir
ou pas non moi je pense qu'elle aurait
dû rester jusqu'à la fin de la saison
et après leur prise de décision un
accord alors est peut-être une rupture
de contrat
d'accord à la rentrée on l'aurait vu
peut-être sur une autre chaîne sera un
autre alors nous on va voir on va la
voir dans les prochains jours sachez le
avec 6,8
on va voir voilà c'est ce qu'elle a
envie de faire le patron de cevital
avoir en francs capitaux
voilà dans les prochains jours d'avoir
ce qu'elle a envie de faire peut-être
sur la chaîne ou pas est en tout cas on
vous donnera des nouvelles dès qu'on en
aura